[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'en peux plus que je souffre d'un
coffre auquel bastringue
même si je reviens et cherchant à 6
sachant qu est ce que vous avez vu j'ai
rien vu qui va changer
je tairai les leurs et syndiqué à
travers un tempo trio qui ne paient pas
part à la promesse été lancé sous les
roues des tours de tchatche tombe sur
une bande de marseillais qui se
partageaient les cartouches et là un
grand barbu bras lu tout vu
cette grève à ce que je veux là dessus
que nous sommes barbuda baiser sud
couvre pas c'est un autre qui vont nous
suivre comme ça jusqu'au verdict me
rappelant tous le coût de leur museau en
les gones
gvt est allé sans de morimond reste que
j'aurais plus d'agrément a traversé
carrousel sous les coups de feu la
recevoir à bout portant de fusillades de
baisers qui tousse tousse empoisonné la
connaît c'est que madame la duchesse
aura marché avec cette bêtise objet la
tête en bas comme un oignon
non je veux dire que madame la duchesse
aura posé le pied sur le sol au lieu de
glisser sur le tapis comme une déesse
que je suis bien c'est la façon avec ça
sur mon blog je garde hi fi toi et puis
si kraft n'était pas celle menée par
israël ne paie pas je pense que madame
la maréchale sera satisfaite j'ai et
tailler la base on exactement sur le
patron accepté par l'impératrice et le
bustier sera mieux réussi que celui de
sa majesté que je n'ai pas eu la
satisfaction
que je n'ai pas eu la satisfaction
d'essayer moi-même sur est la cause
l'emprunt ne met pas que d'essayage soit
fait par d'autres que les dames d'atouts
tiens v'là jaloux qui veulent pas qu'on
voit sa femme en jupe au bas il est
tellement fait rude elle pas fait la
chute est harmonieux les lignes sont
amples c'est pourquoi flèche tour plage
oui donnez leur de vous permettez comme
ceci voilà c'est un peu plus gracieux
rester bien gênant cest gredine de peu
[Musique]
cependant pour monter à cheval alors là
chien c'est mon pire cheveux et un poids
record
je passais bien ce balayage là et m6
à
[Applaudissements]
marc charmante ma charge tu marches en
deux tranches à 7 mois c'est le moment
d'essayer la rébellion selon l'avocat
ordre de l'homme la duchesse aller
coucher billère non ça veut dire ça j'ai
dit la barbie a pas parlé alors vous
avez bien fait de défendre vos glorieux
jupons contre l'assaut des manteaux de
cours
je t'en serai leur synthèse comme il
convient mais le fait ne se produira
plus d'ailleurs nous allons concilier
tout cela nous garderez vos galons aussi
bien gagner et vous resterez la maréchal
lefebvre duchesse de dantzig seul membre
seulement vous éviterez de paraître à la
cour vous devez vous sentir dépaysé et
mal à l'aise ça me privera guerre parce
que je m'amuse à votre cou et oui c'est
ce que je disais c'est un bourreau mais
tout ça est trop d'emplois les amis sont
tous en maintenant leur coller à quoi
qu'ils ont avalé leur princesse les
femmes au port d'armes avec tous leurs
appareils
à quoi vous allez les passe en revue
c'est moins bien évidemment qu'un balle
de barry a batu sûr c'était plus jovial
à la râpée et un du temps que j'étais
blanche est ce ça à cela je le savais
caroline me l'a dit et c'est ridicule
vous avez donc fait tous les métiers
brassage avec 2 ou bien celui là est
elle trop vivandière rôle le drapeau
anobli tous les blanchisseuses ou qu'en
mai à paris ses rangs 91 et 12 où j'ai
lâché la partie rapport au non respect
enfin les émigrés qui filait les soldats
qui se faisait tuer d'autres qui
faisaient fortune et publié payer leur
note ainsi thouaré et vous qui a dans ce
palais un militaire qu'a fait son chemin
celui là semblent des équipes doit
encore de ce temps la soixantaine de
fond que j'ai jalouser durée que non
mais je vous conseille ce serait d'un
bel effet et je me suis même autorisé de
nous apporter sa [ __ ] vous figurer que
l'emploi va arriver vos comptes de
blanchisseuse vous vous êtes folle alors
finissons il est à plat satur que tout
le monde fasse comme votre débiteur qui
oublie sa dette et votre ancien métier
échec royaux rafraîchir la mémoire
escalettes rescue demande crédit sur ma
maigre aux soldes
il me faut c'est mal écrit vous savez il
me faut encore venir en aide à ma mère
et à mes serres qui vont se réfugier à
marseille
vous dites étant forcés de quitter la
corse et cet été
oui non maman et space s'avère l'effet
russe à taiwan la rue des sorties en
effet oui mais attendez si votre nom que
je cherche la traduction non l'autre le
surnom ah oui madame attendez attendez
attendez
madame sans-gêne la mena et vous sied
bien comment cette bonne figue et
c'était moi ma voisine
à l'aune de la part de qui a bien ne
quittez pas je vais l'appeler murray
n'est pas seul ici non oh je vous avais
dit de partir on sait
[Applaudissements]
elizabeth taylor elizabeth taylor oui
bonjour aussi tenir l'appareil
on part était dernier sa mélodieuse à
havard you find daumier web radio san
francisco reuters com non il ya occupe
elle occupe aide comprend rien
comme on dit occuper bézy to business
and what al-othman y écrivant beauty
force for the children chine à y est m
maille électrique roller fort seule
cellule et or n'ont forcé la jeune
espoir plateau bac minutes haletantes de
stores qu'est ce qu'elle dit aux deux
kilos en une semaine à tous qu'il
arrivait week on avait 12 mai 2006 aussi
je voulais te vas y on sacralise la
nation sera wendel c'était vraiment
elizabeth taylor également
et vous qui êtes vous jeudi le ballet se
présenter pour la place de collection en
battant il a une bonne tête
comment vous appelez-vous franck comme
sinatra j'adore moi aussi je l'engagé
tout de suite je crains qu'il soit un
peu jeune bien lors des pics ans et à
défaut il va manquer d'expérience dans
son travail
quelle chance enfin alexandre oukidja
complexe bon eh bien alors laissez-nous
votre adresse on réfléchit la baisse est
de réfléchir est ici maintenant laissez
moi quand je ne sais rien de lui demande
si rien vu on sait qu'il est jeune et
robuste soigner il a les yeux noirs
qu'il est agréable à regarder qui a les
connaissances en anglais et qu'il aime
sinatra c'est largement suffisant pour
s'y réfugier à passer l'aspirateur vers
nous on n'a même pas discuter les
conditions et en plus il est
désintéressé c'est une paire ce garçon
ne laissait pas partir on vous aura
faire moi c'est quand même vrai que joël
non pour la plupart sont de véritables
places nous manque ce sont des pierres
des grosses pierres
quand une valeur en soir et non pas par
le travail du joaillier comme ça c'est
beaucoup plus facile à revendre le casa
shore puis senti mentalement je tiens
beaucoup à ce bijou
chacun représente une étape de ma
carrière et madame a eu beaucoup
d'étapes pratiquement je n'ai eu que des
électeurs ont dit oui je marquais chatte
étape d'une pierre blanche
une pierre de lune ombrée y en a
finalement sera fragile au début mon
dieu sang n'a fait qu'un modeste
ruisseau et puis petit à petit ça fait
une petite rivière qui a coulé tous les
coups les coûts les coûts les poumons
madame doit beaucoup plus tenir à cette
petite rivière
elle aussi elle tient à voir si vous
voyez comme elle s'agrippe à mon cou en
riant nomme avec ses petits diamants ci
furent si bien taillée ça je suis sûr
que ça vous attendrir est hors sûrement
parce que moi je suis très sensible au
jeu les choses alors vous aimeriez
sûrement bon pendentifs en émeraude une
merveille et pourtant il en a fait
valser j'ai même failli perdre d'un
bouton mal classés ou non pas voir le
bouton d'un veston à monsieur est riche
dans ces marais oui c'est on la retrouve
et non dans vos lèvres son compte à
l'ombre c'était la mode à l'époque pas
général furent méthodologie eu peur moi
je comprends ça parce que c'est toujours
en milieu perrin oui même quand on en a
d'autres 1 parce que je pense que madame
à d'autres bijoux en bas j'ai toute ma
petite famille de faire une famille
nombreuse à la la
olala c'est ça j'en ai tellement elles
sont tellement grosse que les gens
procès sont fausses mais elles sont
vraies alors d'un éclat c'est bien
simple j'ai vraiment et rentre-dedans
broche 1 et bien quand je les porte ses
tatouages et sourire
suis pas possible rien qu'avec les
regardant mais qu'elle suscite peut-être
les amorties monsieur les faits auraient
mondiale m
on perd en paix oui c'est une cliente
américaine qui me l'avait offert à
l'institut l'uefa lifting il avait
rajeuni de vingt ans en partant elle m'a
dit vous êtes une fille et une amie
ghanem sur la tête
trois mois après divorce et pourrait
poser avec son fils et quinze jours plus
tard elle vous répétez dénonçant là il
me ferait un gros solitaire pour me
remercier d'avoir dénoncé son cher ses
bijoux
c'est le fruit de mon travail je les
porte fièrement la tête haute
surtout il ya des mythes et une carrière
ça ça n'est pas comme massa tu vois ça
dure massa tuera aux platines on platini
c'est le cadeau de mon premier
admirateur en fuite et fouillent tfo il
avait 46 rectorat depuis que moi oui il
avait vu il avait vu quelque part tu un
jour un homme avait offert une ceinture
en or à polaire nous avait paul r oui et
toi les de la danse oui c'est long c'est
pourtant avec une jeune femme
pour moi il a voulu faire beaucoup mieux
et au plus grand forcément polaire la
porte du temps avec 45 de tour de taille
et moi pas
alors ça doit représenter une somme
énorme mais non mais non ne faut rien
exagérer non
et ça continue
autant vous dire tout de suite ça
continue mais ça tu as des proportions
grandiose
j'ai pourtant l'habitude d'être heureuse
d'être gâtée par la vie est question
bowler pour m'étonner il en faut eh bien
je suis étonné depuis six semaines je
n'arrête pas d'être étonné novembre et
oui non mais vous les verrez c'est un
genre quand même qu'on n'aime pas moi
j'aime alors beaucoup donc je ne vais
pas entrer dans les détails parce qu'il
n'ya pas que ça là haut il ya ça un
texte mais pendant que la spirit parce
que je me sens la tête un peu le haut
par rapport à ça c'est demain alors
pourquoi mais je suis toujours un peu
déçu quand tu ne ressens pas les mêmes
choses que moi et en même temps tout le
temps comme ça des attentions des
compliments des douceurs pas le moindre
petit point de désaccord
s'il vient à baisser dès qu'il faut
jouer à tous et rigaud et le faire une
peinture murale pour la salle de bain et
moi je ne veux pas il dit que ça sera
joli moi je dis que ça ne sera pas très
joli c'est tout
60 ans bien les secousses en temps je
suis laid mais qu'est ce qui t'a rien en
six semaines c'est la deuxième fois que
thomas sérieuse c'était quand la
première fois le premier jour quand je
vois la part de ta belle soeur tu ne te
rappelles part si tu avais oublié de
payer ton pauvre hère coordonne ces
quelques oreilles impossible que tu lui
avait demandé marc avons trop plein et
pour ma salle de massage par la cnss qui
en a fait une tête quand tu te présenter
la facture et ça c'est bien simple sur
le moment j'ai cru que tu ne pouvais pas
la peine que je ne peux garder un
facture amusant mais j'ai jamais très
bien compris pourquoi tu étais si
troublée en voyant doublé n'exagère
aurait assez auprès d'autres surprises
et la turbie avoir retiré sa tous les
moindres détails de notre rencontre sont
inscrits là et je les relis tous les
soirs en m'endormant qui était devant
cette porte moi j'étais devant ce canapé
toi tu avais ton sourire ironique et moi
je n'ai jamais menti kiloutou
mais c'est vrai je n'ai que des
compliments mais j'en ai conclu qu'il y
avait du goût en tout cas le même que
devient et cinq minutes après dans ce
qu'est ce que je t'ai demandé de changer
la décoration de ton d'entrée et après
celle de la salle à manger et tout de
suite après celle de la chambre
maintenant celle de ma salle de bain
tiens tiens pour pour la salle de bains
mais muni l'esata pâture renonce à la
peinture murale non
ab disant content je crois que j'ai
trouvé la solution en mer dans les
projets sont la rose je vous dois
vérifier les mesures à mon temps parlé
j'aurais dis le moi tout de suite ce
n'est peut-être pas réalisable je
voudrais pas de créer de fausses joies
et puis j'ai tellement peur de décevoir
il va y arriver ça va vous suivez avec
ça va me plaire
il va être content et du chum jeter dans
ses bras et ça c'est encore ça pue
attentes n'en faut faire quelque chose
il faut qu'on lui fasse quelque chose
mais bon sans bon sens un grand garçon
comme ça ça n'a pas dû semer que des
roses
il a dû en faire souffrir des femmes il
va le faire souffrir mais comme j'avais
une épée de damoclès ici maintenant et
il a quand même le droit de savoir
comment elle va m'arriver là
enfin il me dit mais ça fait longtemps
vous seulement un petit moment où je
crois que le perso je vais repartir mais
bien dès 11h excusez moi je me suis mise
en retard j'étais sous la douche
dégouline de partout et entra très
attention à la navy dont trois charmants
charmant trois partenaires a surtout
bien exposé je suis inondé de soleil on
ne le fait pas trop attention les hommes
la femme de ménage est malade en ce
moment mais je veux pas vous faire
perdre votre temps voilà la noble en
question à part si vous voulez mais on a
toujours été rose en plus tôt
j'avais perdu et s'hydrater
vous savez celle à tort mon venir du
jour ah ça va pas quelque chose on
séparer mais avant je me rappelle d'une
part parce qu'avec ce que je veux
retirer je pourrai refaire entièrement
l'appartement mais on voulait avant tout
dépôt oui monsieur les mêmes estampillé
je ne sais plus marquée des sentiers
quelque part ça m'ennuie vous décevoir
mais mme dubreuil et je ne suis pas
qualifié pour nous prononcer
formellement mais j'ai bien l'impression
qu'il s'agit d'une coque une copie une
bonne copie du siècle dernier ma femme
que c'est impossible il a été acheté
chez un grand antiquaire du faubourg
saint-honoré sauf une photo d'eux mêmes
qu'ils provenaient de la chambre et du
baril a loupé son agent doute fort plus
je l'examiné plus à conviction que votre
valeur du jour est faux archi faux archi
faux bond à l'heure du jeu mon avis
monsieur personne et que personne n'est
patron mais enfin quand je pense au prix
que je les payais je revois encore
souvent d'identité nationale jacques
adresseront le premier rang il a signé
une facture le meilleur cours regardez
moi monsieur
est ce que j'ai une tête à conserver les
factures moi non je me suis fait avoir
comme d'habitude et noir c'est une
catastrophe
mais à votre place jean de surpris que
j'avais très agréablement nous mêmes à
nous sommes de la profession ça ne me
suis pas mère du jour c'était ma poire
pour la soif et finalement la poire pour
dire non ça va me suis ça va
c'est vraiment des années maintenant
avec souley mais janot 30 ans il s'était
trompé dans je vous remercie moi je suis
en train de me rue des foulons valeur du
jour quelle horreur cette ce tableau
quel tableau mme legrand nul à habas
boni ne connaît pas à baby n'est pas à
vendre
et pour ceux qui sortiraient d'ailleurs
je sais il est totalement inconnue c'est
injuste j'ai toujours pensé comme un
bolide avait du talent un détail qui
vous amusera peut-être monsieur c'est un
mandat qui a servi de modèle aux il est
vrai que sans don pas vous dire grand
chose non plus à manta amende elle
chante bien et beaucoup de succès il ya
vingt ans dire qu'il a complètement
disparu comme s'ils étaient tombés dans
une trappe
c'est drôle on se demande souvent ce
qu'elle te viennent ces vieilles d'aig
je le sais pas pour les autres villes
vedette mais en ce qui concerne le
mandat je peux vous annoncer qu'elle ne
se porte pas trop mal merci parce que ça
ne s'est pas seulement cette fois en
chair et en os
l'annoncé vraiment confuse a fait de
danser la nuit 10 auxerre idiot j'aurais
dû me reconnaît d'autant plus que le
portrait très ressemblant et vous n'avez
pas vu tout sens et aussi un peu tout de
même
non monsieur du sis sur 6 et moi j'ai
passé un peignoir ça alors vous êtes
amende
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que c'est que ce carnaval
mais comment tu ne la trouve pas divine
la robe en satin chrétienne va prêter il
regarde où la soucoupe tattoo ne pas la
prétention de sortir avec monsieur félix
dans 70 ou alors tu es complètement
folle tu vas chez toi je poste de maire
qui n'y connait rien faire c'est le
compte du chis oms a lâché robe là près
de paris la clcv pop
on dit même on dit même que mobility
l'apporter au bas de l'électricité je
meurs femme arabe
écoutez je vais je m'assurais moins
possible d'autant plus évident et c'est
un but partout elle mettait un peu large
et tout prix des douze nouveaux ça va
être pratique au théâtre et au
restaurent que la voix de la raison peut
être fatigante mais je m'arrangerais jeu
très moi je vais te dire je porte le
ridicule que le conventionnel et de
toute façon je vais aller à l'autre en
eau et ma copie chanel enveloppe brune
s'est tenue à saint malo en tout cas est
moins bien que cette décennie
à partir du moment où moi je me montre
dans un endroit public je ne peux pas
être habillé comme tout le monde il faut
que j'aie tonnes que surprenant
mais voyons mais ne dirait ton paraît
quand même comment suis-je paient pas
leur sort et c'est papa qui sort chez
moi reprenez-vous c'est la panique ma
parole
alors oui moi je ne suis plus une jeune
fille ça va ils seront à son premier bar
au nom non mais celui là est très
important parce que cette aide de
dernier atout journaux qui fait plaisir
quoi choquer les voiles et courage je
compte sur vous une bonne impression
parce que ça les attentions
[Rires]
comédien qu'est ce que tu fais du monde
des lourds et alors
on sait rivage missive la main à la main
comme back raté le fait chaud au coeur
moi non plus je ne vous avais pas oublié
reste aux commandes voilà c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est bon la vie c'est bon les fleurs
c'est bon le cinéma la télé en couleurs
c'est votre avis c'est bon c'est bon
choix par la traviata la mise
c'est votre avis sur vos tombes pour
respirer l'odeur du foie et j'imagine
révolat nerfs c'est bon les plages
élévation postés dans les embouteillages
tréboul maintenant et la nature les
fleurs des shows et les vaisseaux de la
culture ces volets j'aime c'est le vieux
les jours de congés jaunes trois clés du
milieu
[Musique]
ou même trois au 612 veillée pour la vie
et je l'attends 90 entière de la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]